fake news this whole podcast
say what hey that rock wasn't fake news
i'm doing that right now
i got a whole fiance bro uh okay one
one funny thing that ties both these
together okay someone's comment but you
commented on the video we posted on
instagram and he said
oh al stepped on my girl's rock yeah and
then someone comments and said
not the last time a black guy will bleed
for a diamond for a white girl
like jeez
that's a good one right there that's
pretty decent though right that is a
good ass joke there was another one that
i thought was disrespectful
but someone was like why was your girl
on her knees
and hands and knees on the ground and
alex walking around where he would step
on
the ring or something like that like
alluding
to the foul [ __ ] [ __ ] maybe
you're trying to clean up wine or
something that he
allegedly said i see what it is okay so
here's the story of the engagement
okay engagement
we're going to this restaurant okay her
favorite restaurant is cosme okay
a few days earlier i go i'm going to get
this reservation for a favorite
restaurant we always have date night
once a week
date night okay super hard to get a
reservation very hard
you could never most people could never
okay most known in this room
definitely one person actually let me
correct that
anyway so yeah me that's
all okay that's it all right
so we go to this place cosme right
mexican restaurant shout outs to mexico
and mexico's
yeah i love them even some mexicans oh
mexicans get a restaurant suddenly they
ain't letting anybody
close yeah that's your move now you see
how fun it is
right how you see the merits oh you
can't just let any old body in
that's interesting why can't i be in
here well it could inconvenience the
people that are already in here
oh is that what happened we have
capacity corona 70
oh [ __ ] i gonna have to talk to enrique
he's the guy who owns this
the guy from chef's table you know what
the host is the host is a wall
no big deal at all no big deal
you know the guy from chef stable i mean
i don't know him i didn't ask him if he
would make a video for my girl and he's
got no response
i learned my level of fame i could get a
reservation and that's all
so so yeah i think he got a spot by me
in long island city
really yeah i got a michelin star yes
most definitely
and it's bomb have you gone yeah all
right you should definitely go it's hard
to get a reservation i got one mark
you dig it's definitely not that one
different definitely different
it was it was the queen could never you
know look at that yeah you can never
it's definitely different guys it's
probably proven he wasn't even
anyway point is uh we go to this
restaurant at cosme right
okay i'm going to get her the
reservation we do date night
she usually gets the reservations i
don't know anything about food my girl
does all this [ __ ]
i go out in a limb i'm like this her
favorite restaurant i'm going to get it
there and that's where i'm going to
propose
the next day she goes i got us a
reservation at cosme i'm like [ __ ]
okay so now i got to delete her
reservation
so i tell her day of yo 8 30 we're going
to cosmetics she's like no it's at
eight and i'm like oh i did one for 8
30. and she goes
oh [ __ ] is eight do you want me to call
them and tell them to cancel
i can't have her call because the people
the restaurant know i'm proposing
yeah so if she calls all of a sudden
they're gonna make oh you sure you want
to cancel this
this is a big night can't do it so i
call really quick and i just cancel it
and then i hit her back like oh i did it
i'm like hopefully she doesn't [ __ ]
know
i don't do anything i don't know how to
organize anything i do nothing in that
regard
immediately she should be suspicious she
should be very suspicious and she knows
that there's a ring somewhere around
there
i told you the night i got my ring i
lost my phone right what oh
the night i got the ring i went to my
parents house to show my mom the ring
right because my dad never got her a
real ring so i wanted her to see what it
was like
right right wait you said your dad never
got your mama
no my dad this is how wild my mom is my
mom was wearing
the first guy that she was married to
engagement ring
while she was married to my dad oh
no my dad proposed my mom in a taxi cab
on the way to chinese food
that's fire she got a night she got a
ring eventually though she got a ring no
she didn't that's funny
does she wear a ring to this day to this
day she wears a ring she just bought a
fake one and my dad asked her do you
want a ring or like uh do you want
something for the house and then she was
like i'll just do a garden
instead so she just chose to do it that
way but if my dad was like
intuitive he would have just got it he
knows that's what she wants it doesn't
matter anyway show the ring come back
lose my [ __ ] phone
i'm freaking out somehow i find my phone
shout out to this girl that found it
okay we're at this restaurant i'm like
how do i make sure
that she's not gonna gonna do we're not
even at the restaurant yet we go back to
the house
okay this [ __ ] box from lorraine
shorts my boy justin cohen
at lorraine schwartz this is the guy
that you go if you need a ring you go to
him i think it's jcny on instagram
the box is massive it fits in one jacket
okay
i'm obviously not going to bring it to
the studio gotta be the right weather
for the jacket
not only got to be the right weather for
the jacket i'm telling her to pick out
the outfit
okay i got the box inside one of my
jordans in the closet at the top thing
okay i tell her i get home she's in
jeans
i'm like you're not going to want to get
proposed on jeans i'm like baby i've
been so busy
can we just get a little dressed up but
not trying to throw her off she looks at
me she goes
wait a minute as if i'm going to propose
she goes and i go no it's not that i
promise you it's not that trust me
it's not that but let's just get a
little dressed up i'm so busy we have
one night to go out let's just get a
little fancy
i say pick me out an outfit you pick
yourself out outfit
okay you know that prada jacket that i
was wearing last time trying to subtle
flex
yeah like i didn't know how expensive
that [ __ ] was that i wore and um thank
you so much to everybody that noticed it
i appreciate you
[ __ ] all y'all that thought it was just
a regular jacket that is regular
no it's not regular bro that's prada
you probably haven't been in the store
it's really hard to get in it's it's
really difficult
but two people got a reservation the
same night can we not we're not gonna
acknowledge it
yeah okay i'm just saying the restaurant
was [ __ ] empty i walked in there
francis ellis was eating with his
girlfriend i almost walked out
i almost walked out i was like how is it
going to be special if francis is right
here
not proposing you know how miserable
that night was for him oh said i waited
for him to leave
i couldn't do it in front of him and his
girl after a beautiful dinner i just
bust out the
rock blind everyone in the restaurant
sitting there all naked-handed
you can't have that happen just
eviscerate everyone yeah
exactly infinity stone so i go
i go i hope she picks this one jacket
there's one jacket that's going to fit
in
i tried it in every other jacket you
know me i don't have that many things
i got a [ __ ] jean jacket i got the
black and yellow north face doesn't fit
in either of those
it fits in the prada pocket thank god
she picks a prada pocket i'm okay okay
we're good we're in there
on our way to the restaurant that's huge
exactly before we go to the restaurant
by the way
i go downstairs to walk the dog on my
way back i'm pretty sure i see the dude
from the penthouse
this is an old story this is for people
who don't know but she dated someone
who's in the building just happens to be
the nicest
apartment in the building and everything
like that so i see i'm pretty sure i see
the guy i'm not exactly sure pathetic
looking guy
i saw a guy was pretty pathetic and i
was like that's probably maybe a
homeless guy or something yeah it might
have been hard couldn't even recognize
who he was yeah i walked right out of
the building i was like get the [ __ ]
riffraff
throw him a quarter yeah there you go
buddy best of luck
so i go we're on the way we go to the
restaurant
restaurant knows i'm proposing in
between the meal
and the dessert okay i got a line set up
that i said i'm brilliant idiots
it's right that [ __ ] was fire i have it
written in my phone
because i know i'ma [ __ ] it up i go what
are you doing
forever in retrospect that [ __ ] really
is
bad but when i said it on brilliant
idiot charlotte really gassed me up he's
gotta be
the next few days i was like yeah i
don't know this is fire he wasn't saying
it right
how do i say it you're supposed to be
like grab my hand like so what are you
doing for the rest of your life
fire yeah you got a goatee and some game
over here
all right i've seen you taylor ever
since you put on that face pain you're
good at lying
i don't know what that is what the hell
happened what the hell
okay damn near colonizing my pickup line
okay so i'm in there i go to the
bathroom to check my phone
just get the line i got the line what
are you doing forever i got it we're
sitting there
i'm like okay the second this food is
out the way we're [ __ ] doing it i'm
dropping it i check it again she tells
me to get off my phone giving me
attitude about me being on my phone i'm
like oh you almost didn't get the
proposal
you're gonna yell about me because i
can't memorize the goddamn line i want
to use to spend the rest of my life with
you
she was calling you out she was like yo
can you just put your phone down we're
on date night and i was like
i'm going on my script yeah what's wrong
don't you want a happy ending to this
movie
i'm reading my side you're [ __ ]
reading live that's right
memorize that line exactly when you're
nervous bro
i wasn't that sound next thing as [ __ ]
when you're nervous bro
but what's so nervous about it though i
don't know it's just the moment
you know i got [ __ ] francis right
it's too many things happening right
yeah you said there was a
whiteness blinded off the phone
what are you doing for never this whole
sound right francis white in an akash
right
real talk didn't you say there were
other people in the restaurant you
recognized oh and then
they're halfway through other people
from our building came in all right [ __ ]
them you
know it was a penthouse dude say what
penthouse no no no other people that we
like that we like
everything's fine anyway i can't believe
i go like this i go hey
um we're just eating blah blah i'm
gearing up for it and she goes
yeah i was doing this like mba interview
you know she's getting her master's and
she's doing like trying to do interviews
to get a job right
and she was like and i call you like my
boyfriend and it just sounds so juvenile
calling you my boyfriend
and then i just go i go i go uh yeah we
should change that
and i just got down on one knee and i
busted it open and then
she just said she just blacked out okay
now i still need to ask
so i asked her i wanted to say what are
you doing i want to say
will you spend the rest of your life
with me all right and i said
will you spend the less of your life
with me right
i just became chinese yes
in the middle i said will you spend the
last of you arriving
this guy loves a freaking asian accent
i turned into the vietnamese person
so no that was just a homage to your dad
when your parents were
getting chinese food oh dude that's very
romantic
beautiful so she doesn't even
answer so i have to go like you have to
answer she answers put the ring down she
did the oh like that
she laughed like a yeah that's what they
did
wait a minute like asians laughing or
like a white girl really excited she's
oh right they're so excited
oh that's hilarious taylor goes taylor
goes did she go oh
and covers her mouth yeah and i'm
assuming she's laughing like an asian
i'm just saying this everybody listening
at home but you know yeah she did that
okay um and this is where [ __ ] gets cool
so
uh i mark mark was very helpful he went
to the crib
with his girl with his wife and took
care of the dogs
took all of who he don't even like yo i
killed that yeah
they killed it you did kill this took
care of the dogs took all of her
computers and like work stuff
and brought to this hotel because i took
her to this hotel okay
and we got this like beautiful sweetness
hotel shout out to my boy laurent for
hooking everything up
and um pound the puss yeah
yeah i'm so drunk i don't even remember
real talk i have no [ __ ] recollection
but we went in there and she was all
taken care of she didn't have to worry
about the dogs everything was good
and um it was beautiful and uh
woke up the next day violently hung over
i didn't i didn't dhm i should have d h
them
and um we leave
and on our way out there's a guy who's
the
the what's it called cleaning room guy
yeah he was going out right
and um we leave and as we leave the guy
goes uh
to me he's this asian dude happy
thanksgiving
and uh i go that's weird i guess it's i
guess almost thanksgiving i don't know
what the hell
the deal does so i go thanks man happy
thanksgiving and uh
my girl just starts dying laughing
i'm like why why are you laughing what
the [ __ ] is going on
and then uh she goes uh he said
housekeeping
you thought he said happy thanksgiving
bro i thought he said
i thought he said he said housekeeping
but i thought that he said happy
thanksgiving
how [ __ ] up where are you i was bad it
was really bad celebrating yo was he an
asian guy
no he was an asian dude yeah yeah yeah
his whole story is full circle yeah yeah
really
it was beautiful and you just left
imagine no there was like an like an
asian angel that was just like watching
over to me to make sure everything oh
asian jesus that's sean king's favorite
dude so anyway that is my engagement
story
and um it is all done i got a fiancee
thank you so much
congratulations
about marriage and stuff yeah we yeah we
know i think that's the thing about
being engaged is like
uh it doesn't change anything for the
guy because the second i'm willing to
buy you a ring i'm willing to marry you
i'm married in my mind the second i said
i'm buying a ring
we're married we're married so for her
it's the validation that it is true
that i want to marry you right so for
her i guess it was a way
bigger deal there's like proof every
single day that i want to spend the rest
of my life with her but for me
i know that that's why i bought it yeah
so but yeah i don't know i guess i'm
grown now guys
you say fiance you see my girl i haven't
said fiance yet like
without correcting myself it's mad
syllables yo it is it gets exhausting
real fast every time i say fiance i'm
like this is my wife yo
and she's just like no we haven't had
the wedding and i'm like yeah but y'all
had the important wedding we had we
didn't have her religious ceremony
but you have yours yeah so for me i'm
married for her we're not but it's my
wife i don't know wait
wait what is it for you you're a
different religion so we had the hindu
ceremony because like the calendar is
very important
and yeah what's hers though then
she's sick she's sick so that's that's
not you don't it don't matter there's no
like
favorable time or whatever so we're
going to have that with the actual
ceremony reception all that
okay well it is what it is
your boys out the game official yeah i
think it's a kofo celebration
now we need a we need cups doc oh you
could take it to the fate
okay that's for you and your shorty
congratulations man
so thank you so much
you gotta get used to that it ain't
gonna be about you for a long time
the question is when are you going down
boy out of here
how come why not yo taylor when you get
married
yeah well i have a story oh okay boom
baby no no don't let it go
no my story doesn't even like it doesn't
even matter you are the one
black women matter taylor black women
matter so we know black women matter
yeah
okay yeah but mine doesn't really it
doesn't do anything hold on
we're going to get two mores in a second
y'all are the ones i propose not me
so taylor taylor hold on one second can
we go al can you please tell us what the
deal is
what i'm when are we popping one i just
turned 33 i guess my hands aren't strong
enough
oh my god
now listen tell me a hundred percent
tell me a hundred percent hundred
percent
why are you not engaged and when are you
getting engaged
and to whom you're a piece of [ __ ]
you really are hi you're a real piece of
[ __ ] why am i pissed
why are you doing this right now why do
i i'm just asking bro it's a question i
can't ask questions
i think he doesn't want to see anyone
else having fun if he can't have fun
that's the thing bro if you hook up with
one chick out here in these streets
he's gonna be so [ __ ] murdered
i'm not the game but i will say that i
just turned 33 i
marriage isn't my future not right now
he's jordan bro and you're lebron out
here
and he's gonna see you winning rings
going what the [ __ ] is this
i'm gonna drop my last dance bruh drop
my last dancer
i'm not gonna lie um i will say this
which is kind of lit
is that uh it's amazing how excited the
fellas get about a bachelor party
the second you post a picture of the
ring because i had a group chat that had
literally 200 messages in it i looked
out of my phone when i woke up the next
morning and then
i was like 15 messages and i was like
all right the boys know they're saying
congratulations
etc i look back like three minutes later
there's 200 messages going and the last
one
is for one of my homies that goes all
right i'm gonna bring security
yeah what are we doing and we need
security so the bachelor party i'm very
excited about yeah
it's gonna be gay people everywhere
that's my bachelor party
um all right so al so when do you think
that you're we have to line up
already being jealous possessive cutting
his foot let's let this man live
yeah i mean i feel pain i'm in pain
right now
wow yeah why add to it by getting
engaged
yeah exactly yo taylor so tell us why
why i mean it wasn't nothing crazy
like i went to we went to the jewelry
store
oh oh oh [ __ ] that's not crazy and what
and we just got some jewelry but the
people there were really trying to like
drill him like oh look at these rings
he was checking them out though so
that's what i'm saying
would you marry him if he asked yeah
get it taylor's off the market
you lock it down yeah you gotta lock
that dick down though
you gotta lock that big now we're
obsessed with your boyfriend's dick here
he's gonna name a whole episode after
him what's his name thor probably
because he got that [ __ ]
hammer he got the hammer the ring's
gotta be as many carrots as his dick is
long
yeah in centimeters
i think that's it's 60. yeah y'all ever
[ __ ] yourself in centimeters
yeah of course what the only way to do
it measured yourself yeah i'm like using
your dick incentives
and you guys said yes i
that's how you do it yeah some girl asks
how big is it you go in in america or in
england
[ __ ] what i'm only giving england
what's an inch to centimeter how many
centimeters are an inch akash go
two point no it's five four it's three
that's three it's like three in a little
bit
it's three in a little bit oh [ __ ] come
on boy out here swinging bro bam
that's got to be at least a little
centimeter extra that's a couple
yeah my man got the snuffalufficus can
we talk about this really quick you got
the snuffball i love it yeah i got the i
got the laura
i'll play with it a lot because yeah we
play with it that is something
you kidding me it's fun to play with
like we have m m's in there and then
find them later
what are you talking about peanuts she
makes him jump off the table and do a
parachute yeah
come on i hold the egg
scene that just slowing himself down
like that's amazing
you never jumped off the table with the
full foreskin yeah and we have full
parachutes like an army man
yeah yeah grab the and play double dutch
come on taylor
what are you talking about it's a
drawstring come on t yeah
you've never played with foreskin before
come on and by the way he got removed
they just keep it and play them how are
you going to say when you're dressed
like foreskin right now taylor
jesus you look like you have some before
you look like a whole foreskin
real [ __ ] it's crazy that little head
piece that you got right there what is
this
that's how it feels you pinch the tip
you can pee in his hair for later
that's her boyfriend's forest getting
mad at facts
no [ __ ] you could have chopped that
off your man that means
black though yeah but you could have
bleached it that's
easy to do or turn it inside out uh-huh
that force can look like it came from
alex
alexpedia
you